sometimes do something that you know you
can do you know when go for it at 150
million percent I just wanted to be the
best be hot and just have something hot
to hear my voice on a radio you don't
have to stop it's just a matter of you
caring enough to always pay attention I
just make my records and let the chips
fall you could do anything you put your
mind to you know saying there's no
limitations to this dad you're fired
you my assistant you're fired to you
you're fine everybody's fine if I'm not
here to maximize my potential then what
am I own earth for you're not successful
- you went 360 degrees full sight for
the full cycle and die then you
successful he's an American hip hop
recording artist and actor from Queens
New York he's known as one of the
forefathers of pop rap he's released 13
studio albums and 2 Greatest Hits
compilations and his kids when they're
growing up there's one stuff they think
that they can't do they're told they
can't be this they can't be that what
you have to do is if you have a
situation like that you have to gain
focus yourself and go for it yourself
you know listen how do you have focus
how would you tell somebody to do that
if they don't have that power they think
they're safe of it you got to get
confidence and find something that you
do feel confident about you know find
something that you feel confident you
can achieve do something that you know
you can do
you know when go for that 150 million
percent how'd you know what was music
that's what I like I know that's what I
love from the first time for me it
doesn't matter what I do I could do all
of the Hollywood stuff and I could you
know and I do all that and everybody
knows about how fun of my life yeah all
of that but you know what there is
nothing on earth more like in fun and
crazy a while for me than just getting
on the records and rhyming and him my
journal radio he might join a club like
like oh I don't even look I could host
of zillion Grammys I could you know do
TV shows and shoot bazookas and blow
cars and do all of that but none of that
another that gives me the adrenaline
rush and the thrill that you know music
gives me you know I'm saying and you
know so when you put your heart and soul
and your passion into something like you
know I can't walk away from that just
because because it never was business
for me it was always personal you know
I'm saying
music there's always personal to me and
I know I know that's almost weird and an
era where it's all about being a
businessman but for me music it was
always personal like I just wanted to be
the best be hot and just have something
hot to hear my voice on a radio be heard
and just feel it that's what my whole
career is based on you know longevity
versatility originality you know I'm
saying like like like giving them the
longevity but being versatile enough to
adapt as time moves on you know and then
being original enough not being a
follower and not like being a guy that
you know you leading the pack and then
when things switch up all of a sudden
you start following but actually keeping
it you know keeping it fresh still
believing in your taste you know I'm
saying I got a lot you know you know a
lot of low young homies that stay around
me and a lot of little cats that I hang
out with and you know and and and stuff
like that but just believing in yourself
and know and doing what you love like
that's the thing I love about this
culture like you don't have to stop it's
just a matter of you caring enough to
always pay attention absolutely well see
with me
I don't concentrate on
black or pop I make an LL record I make
the best record I can make put it out
there and present it to the people you
know I mean if it's like a painting I
mean if 500 people get online to see my
painting today the next painting is
5,000 the next painting is 3,000 and the
next painting is 40,000 and the next
painting is 2,000 and it's 100,000
that's just the way it is you know I'm
interested in in radio play but at the
same time I just make what I make and I
don't know how to cross over I don't
know how to go pop I just make my
records and let the chips fall I got a
line on the UM on the album I don't know
the exact line but I was just basically
saying that you know well my first album
drop Jordan was a rookie
you know then yeah like wow like you
know I'm saying just to put it in
perspective like my friend my first
album cover I had the first ever pair
Jordans from the first release is that
standing on the car yeah no no that's my
second album this is my first one this
is the first one and um you know it's
crazy because you know it just shows you
that you know you could do anything you
put your mind to you know I'm saying
there's no limitations to this there was
a point when I started hearing you know
you having tax problems but my father
was running my whole financial life he
was dealing with the checks he was
dealing with everything I hardly was
doing anything and around that time I
was starting to get back with the mother
of my children I remember looking at my
son and saying to myself you know how
can I look at this this young man here
and tell him I'm his father if I'm not
even taking care of myself
I have all these people around me
telling me what to do and what not to do
who I should be with and who I shouldn't
be with and I have a son here who's
gonna depend on me to take care of him
and look out for him
who raised him dad you fight you my
assistant you're fired too you you're
fine everybody's fine yeah hello yeah
I'm trying to figure out where the GED
program is oh I know where it is my
uncle tells me go out there join in
you understand I'm saying it's like
there's a period you know you got to
take control you got to take the reins
yes I have people in my life that help
me because you know a wise man attains
wise counsel obviously and you want to
have that mastermind principle going on
gonna have a lot of people around you
have a think tank flowing but at the
same time like you got to be able to
take care of your own life and that was
what was important to me I decided you
know what I want to be able to take care
of my own life I have to be able to be
in charge on some level and what are you
willing to sacrifice the game you have
to sacrifice your integrity you have to
sacrifice who you are as a human being
and principles of values head and still
believed by the mentors when your family
you may have to sacrifice um sleep the
successful people can just we lost a lot
of sleep oh yeah
it's high
you know just just believe in yourself
so I say that to say to say this keep
going up your dreams keep going after he
goes pursue them relentlessly did deep
down into your soul hold on to that
between that society you don't let it go
no matter what you like a pig or be like
a tiger just attack your dreams with
aggression and power but people like
while you're doing it have faith in
yourself have faith in your God listen
to your mentors and love you you know my
mother used to tell me Todd you can do
anything you put your mind to
and my grandmother used to tell me if a
task is once begun never leave it till
it's done be thy labor great or small do
it well or not at all and I kind of grew
up with that mantra you know I grew up
believing that you can do anything you
put your module hmm you know and I don't
no matter what you know I am extremely
determined yeah like I'm like you know
abnormally that need to succeed never
goes away right it's not only it's not
just a like a general six like succeed
for the success for the sake of
succeeding it's it's a desire to create
you know I'm saying to use the godly
power and talent that was instilled in
me to the best of my ability to maximize
my potential because if I'm not here to
maximize my potential then would in my
own artful tiny set girls here self
beside what you want to do and do it the
quicker you set your goals the quicker
you achieve them as you achieve them
they change so what would make you and
then you go to bed at night what makes
you think
yeah I'm successful what you know I
don't feel like I'm successful success
to me is living a complete life
you know being rich physically mentally
and spiritually and dying rich
physically mentally and spiritually and
then ascend into a higher place that's
success because you can say you're
successful in the next day lose what you
thought made you successful so um you're
not successful - you went 360 degrees
full safe on a full cycle and died then
you're successful because you completed
life you were successful with the whole
thing where did you get that me yeah
this is something that came from your
mom or your parents or really because it
does ascribe to some certain religious
ideas for me this is something I feel is
that but my life force tells me - thank
you so much for watching we made this
video because Rodney asked us to if you
have another entrepreneur you want us to
profile leave it in the comments below
I'd also love to know which of LL Cool
J's top 10 rules hit you the hardest
leaving the comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon